[Music]
a good ending can make or break a horror
movie
fortunately for fight fans the 21st
century has been full of fantastic
finales
that have sent us scrambling under the
covers in fear and from ghostly
apparitions to bloodthirsty vampires
here are the greatest and here's your
warning spoilers for
all these movies of course the descent
has
everything you'd want in a horror film
plenty of gore great performances
practical effects and two endings that's
right
there are two versions of this british
horror film one released in the uk
and one in the us the film comes to a
close after our last surviving character
sarah spots a shaft of light
atop a hill of bones covered in blood
sarah makes a mad scramble for the exit
leaving the cave dwelling creatures
behind emerging into the sunlight
sarah hops in a car and makes her great
escape but that all comes to a screaming
halt when she sees the ghost of her old
friend juno
a woman sarah just killed for having an
affair with her husband
that's where the u.s version ends but in
the original uk version
there are a few extra scenes that reveal
sarah never actually escaped the caverns
that whole sequence was just a dream
sarah had after tumbling down a shaft
and hitting her head
in her last moments sarah sees her long
dead daughter
sitting a few feet away greeting her
mother with a birthday cake
of course there's no little girl and the
flames from the birthday candles are
really sarah's torch
sarah is still trapped and there's no
escaping the crawlers as they move in
for the kill
but at least she'll get to share her
last few seconds with her daughter
even if it's all in her head
at first it might seem like let the
right one in
ends on an upbeat romantic note two star
cross lovers
oscar a 12 year old boy and ely a
vampire who looks like a young girl
have just escaped a swedish town filled
with sadists and snoke
bound together by murder and romance
light-sensitive
eely is hidden away inside a box but
oscar keeps the creature company by
tapping out sweet morse code messages
letting ely know they'll always be
together think about it though
we've already seen what happens to
people who pledge their lives to ely
in the first half of the film ely was
paddling around with an adult named
hawken
who hunted down humans and drained them
of their blood to keep ely fed
but hawking eventually botches a job so
badly that he knows his arrest is
imminent
he disfigures his own face so the cops
can't identify him
and won't trace him back to the vampire
eventually
the vampire shows up for a late night
hospital visit
and hawken lets the undead beast feast
on his blood
that's probably what's in store for
oscar sooner or later
oscar will dedicate his life to draining
people dry
and sooner or later he'll find himself
haunted by his deeds
and replaced by somebody younger after
ending up the next meal for an undead
adolescent
bleep in drag me to hell a bank worker
named christine is cursed after denying
a loan extension
in three days a demon called the lamia
will pull christine into hell
and he's going to torture her every
second until that devilish date
however christine discovers a way to
escape the lamia's clutches
if she gives the curse button away she
can avoid winding up in the underworld
ready to get some revenge of her own
christine digs up the now dead woman's
grave
who cursed her and shoves the button
down her throat
only there's one little problem
christine has been keeping the button in
an envelope
unfortunately her boyfriend has an
identical envelope with a rare coin
inside
and christine gets the two confused so
after her late night cemetery excursion
she goes to meet her beau at a train
station and that's when he casually
mentions finding the button in his car
terrified of what's about to happen
christine absolutely freaks out
staggering backwards in shock tumbling
off the railway platform and landing on
the train tracks below
but before she can get mercifully
squished by an oncoming locomotive
the ground opens up and she's dragged
into hell by a mob of fiery arms
that's how you end a movie resolution is
a deeply unsettling and underseen film
about two friends
who are trapped in a real-life horror
movie when graphic designer michael
receives a mysterious video from his
junky friend chris
michael decides it's intervention time
michael drives out to chris's country
cabin
handcuffs him to a pipe and forces his
buddy to go cold turkey
however the intervention veers into
spooky territory
when michael starts discovering photos
records and slides all around the cabin
they all depict incredibly creepy
stories that usually end in depth
and things get way scarier when michael
and chris start finding videos
of themselves videos that show them
getting killed by drug addicts
the two eventually realize they're the
victims of an evil entity
that sees them as characters in a horror
story the duo tried their best to
outsmart the beast
and they certainly seem to the druggies
who've been threatening them throughout
the film are killed
the haunted cabin is set ablaze and
chris decides to go to rehab
it's the perfect happy ending one they
hope will set them free
as the cabin burns to the ground the
entity rears its monstrous head and
confronts the two characters
desperate for another chance michael
begs
can we try it another way
and that's the end creepy the babadook
belongs to a very unique sub-genre of
scary films
movies about parents who can't stand
their kids
the babadook actually ends on an upbeat
note unlike many others in this genre
the terrorized mom overcomes her demons
and starts a new life for herself and
her son
amelia was widowed the same day she gave
birth to her son
samuel now whenever she sees her kid she
can only think about her dead husband
needless to say amelia isn't handling
her grief well
she's let it fester and grow for so long
that there's now a fanged creature with
a fondness for pop-up books hanging
around her house
the babadook even possesses amelia
forcing her to try and murder samuel
but after driving the demon out amelia
comes to terms with her grief
and sends the babadook scurrying down to
the basement
in the film's final minute we see a
transformed amelia in her garden
her anger towards samuel has disappeared
together the two search their yard for
worms
and after filling a bowl with the
creatures amelia takes the dish down to
the basement
where she offers the worms to the
babadoo even though she's exercised the
beast
he's still lurking down there and just
like amelia's grief
he'll never go away completely it's a
chilling metaphor for grief and anger
and a great closing though movies often
have twisted endings
but the ending to the black coat's
daughter is just downright sad
this atmospheric film follows two
teenage girls
left behind at a boarding school the
semester is over but these two are stuck
their parents nowhere in sight
that's perfectly fine with rose a senior
with a secret she needs to deal with
but poor cat isn't handling the
abandonment well
thanks to a creepy dream about her
parents fate she fears she'll be left
alone forever
so naturally cat makes a deal with the
devil the demon makes her commit
horrible deeds
but cat legitimately feels at peace
after she's caught by the cops
an exorcist kicks the demon out of cat
and even though she begs the spirit
to stay old scratch drifts away leaving
cat
all alone again years later kat has
escaped from a mental hospital and plans
on returning to her school
hoping to find her demonic buddy along
the way she's picked up a middle-aged
couple
who happened to be the parents of rose
the senior that cat decapitated back in
the day
things don't end well for the destroyed
parents but when cat shows up at the
school with two fresh heads in tow
the demon is nowhere to be found that's
when it hits cat that she'll be alone
forever
and the film ends with her crying in the
snow abandoned by everyone
crimson peak tells the devastating story
of edith cushing
an american heiress who marries charming
english aristocrat thomas sharp
sharp is an inventor who lives in a
mansion ravaged by time
a dying house sinking into the blood red
earth and when edith arrives at sharp's
crumbling estate
she learns she won't exactly be the lady
of the house
as thomas lives with his cold
calculating sister lucille
actually thomas and lucille are doing
way more than just living together
in addition to having a physical
relationship the penniless siblings have
been keeping afloat
by getting thomas hitch to wealthy women
and then killing off the unlucky brides
edith discovers she's next on the
shark's list but a lovestruck thomas
agrees to help edith escape
lucille offs her brother and confronts
edith
morphing into a ghostly slasher and
fluttering through the fog as edith
holds her off with a knife
her ghostly brother distracts her just
long enough for edith to finish her off
edith then leaves crimson peak forever
but as our hero narrates over the final
scene
we see the dark spirit of lucille
sitting at her piano
playing a mournful lullaby for time
eternal
simple but extremely effective
the alien series has never been a
feel-good franchise
but when it comes to downbeat endings
alien covenant goes darker than any
previous entry
the film focuses on a ship full of
humans traveling the stars and hoping to
wake up in a new world full of new
possibilities
these sleeping souls have no idea the
crew has made an ill-fated detour to a
nearby planet
one that's home to killer aliens and a
psychopathic android named david
we first met david in prometheus and his
disdain for humans has only grown since
the first film
he views people simply as subjects for
his experiments
and he'd like to run a few tests on
covenant officer daniels
she escapes david's grasp with the help
of walter
an android who's the same model as david
only way better when it comes to his
people skills
after walter defeats david off screen he
returns to the covenant with daniels and
puts her into cryosleep for their long
journey ahead
but moments before going under walter's
kindly smile
morphs into a sadistic smirk and daniels
realizes this isn't her robo buddy after
all
it's actually david but there's nothing
she can do as she puts her under
with daniels out of the way david coughs
up two alien embryos and strolls through
the massive cryo chamber
admiring the pods full of sleeping
colonists
don't let the bed bugs bite
i'll tuck in the children m night
shyamalan movies are
always judged on the strength of their
endings he's occasionally struggled with
sticking the landing since the sixth
sense
but shyamalan recaptured some of that
glory with split
this 2017 hit follows a disturbed dude
named kevin
a man with 24 personalities bouncing
around his brain
some are friendly some are dangerous but
the dreaded beast is a straight up
monster
a cannibalistic creature who can scale
walls bend metal
and deflect gunshots in the final three
minutes of the film
after the climatic showdown with casey
cook we watch as kevin examines himself
in a mirror
awestruck that he's just survived a
shotgun blast to the chest
and that's where the movie propper ends
with kevin's evil personalities basking
in their new abilities
and plotting their war on the impure
that tim showed the world how powerful
we can be
that right there would be a killer
ending but it's made even better by an
extra scene at a diner the horrified
patrons are watching a news report about
the beast
one customer is reminded of mr glass the
mad genius from shyamalan's 2002 film
unbreakable
and that's when we see david dunn
sipping coffee at the end of the bar
and realizing it's time to grab his
green raincoat
in just one minute the entire fabric of
the film has been changed
split wasn't just a freaky horror movie
it was a stealth sequel to unbreakable
all along mother is one part biblical
allegory
one part environmental metaphor and
totally disturbing from beginning to end
jennifer lawrence stars as the titular
mother wife of a beloved poet known
simply as him
however their little world is threatened
by the arrival of an entire host of odd
people
intent on destroying their home once you
realize that mother represents mother
earth
and him as god things start clicking
into place
the film rehashes several well-known
biblical tales
when mother's newborn baby is murdered
by the masses that's symbolic of
christ's crucifixion
all the people him has welcomed into his
home begin destroying everything in
sight
desecrating the planet earth if you will
and mother can only take so much abuse
for so long
after the death of her baby mother snaps
and fights back by setting the house on
fire
the house is burned to ash the people
are purged away by flames
but since him is an immortal being he
survives without a single burn
the all-powerful poet picks up mother's
charred body
and removes a crystal from her chest
taking the last of her love
so he can rebuild his home create a new
wife and start over again
and that's how this horror show ends
with this cycle beginning anew
all because him craves praise and
affection for his literary creations
baby a quiet place was a critical and
commercial smash when it hit theaters in
2018
and one of the reasons the film was so
successful is the fact that it features
one of the most memorable endings in
horror movie history
a quiet place focuses on the abbott
family who are trying to survive in a
world plagued by monsters
these extraterrestrial creatures are
blind but their sense of hearing is
incredibly acute
knock over a lantern triple on the
stairs or shout in pain
and they'll slice you in hat
on top of that they're covered in
natural armor making them nearly
impossible to kill
as a result the abbots must adapt to
live in a world without sound
keeping as quiet as possible at all
times
because the creature's ears are so
sensitive they can't stand the feedback
from reagan's cochlear implants
so when she and the surviving family
members are trapped in a basement by one
of the beasts
reagan uses her hearing aid to drive one
of the monsters crazy
it starts to arrive in pain allowing
reagan's mother to kill the weakened
creature with a shotgun blast
of course the gunshot attracts the other
nearby aliens
but the abbotts aren't afraid they've
got the upper hand
and as the evil ets make a b-line for
the basement
reagan gets her new weapon ready and her
mom racks another shell into her shotgun
ready to make some noise for all its
sci-fi trappings
annihilation is very much a horror movie
it's got
hideous mutants extreme body horror and
uber creepy plant people
but perhaps the most terrifying scene
comes when natalie portman encounters a
mysterious being
that mirrors her every move annihilation
finds portman playing lena
a soldier turned scientist who's haunted
by guilt and regret
her military husband kane has
disappeared after venturing into the
shimmer
lena blames herself for kane's
disappearance as her bad choices might
have driven her husband to a suicide
mission
but a year after vanishing kane
reappears
confused missing memories and incredibly
sick
i don't know where it was or
what it was how is that possible wanting
to know what happened to kane
lena joins a scientific team heading
into the shimmer
which refracts and combines everything
from memories to dna
she eventually winds up at a lighthouse
where she meets a metallic humanoid
that copies her movements and steals her
likeness
a horrified lena tries to escape but the
humanoid won't let her leave
it even pins her against the door
suffocating lena with the weight of its
body
she escapes but this is where things get
ambiguous
did the real lena escape or is this her
double when she hugs her husband
both their eyes dance and change colors
just like the shimmer
so is this the real lena ultimately it
really doesn't matter
the only thing that does is that lena
has changed
the woman who walked into the shimmer
has come out a completely different
person
confusing but fascinating
upgrade is set in a near future where
most humans are totally cool with having
technological implants
one exception is grey trace but after a
gang of thugs kill his wife and leave
him paralyzed
grave finds himself totally reliant on
technology
thanks to an oddly benevolent
billionaire gray has been implanted with
an ai
named stem stem connects gray's brain to
his body
allowing him to move around for the
first time in months
he's also oddly keen on helping grey
find his wife's killers
together the two stalk the streets
dishing out grisly deaths to the crooks
who ruined grey's life
however at the end of the film grey
discovers stem has been pulling the
strings all along
the ai desperately wanted to be human
and thought gray was the perfect host
so he turned the mechanic into a widowed
quadriplegic
and once he got inside grey's brain he
murdered anyone who knew of his
existence
from the killers to his creator holding
tight to his last shreds of humanity
gray fights back desperately trying to
save an innocent detective
in that struggle grey's mind finally
breaks
his brain goes limp and stem locks him
away in a dream world
a paradise where his wife is still alive
in some ways
it's a happy ending for grey but also
horrifying when you realize that stem
has achieved his final goal
grace not here anymore he's in a better
place
in his mind where he wants to be
hereditary is a tough watch of a film
with an incredibly deranged ending
basically the movie follows a doomed
family that's being manipulated into
bringing a demon named payment into the
world
he's been possessing a little girl named
charlie for a few years
but payman would prefer to possess a
male so his followers plot to transfer
the spirit into charlie's older brother
peter
of course that involves a rather
complicated ritual where you have to
decapitate charlie post a disturbing
seance and set a man on fire
in the last few minutes of hereditary
peter is chased around the house by his
possessed mom
everywhere he runs he keeps bumping into
naked aging cult members
and to cap everything off peter watches
in horror as his mom saws her own head
off with a wire
he's having a rough night it's all too
much for peter who throws himself out a
window
and ends up getting controlled by
payment anyway in the film's final scene
a possessed peter is surrounded by
worshipful cult members
the beheaded corpse of his mom and
grandmother and a freaky shrine that
prominently features charlie's
decapitated head
wholesome family fun all i do
is worry and slay and defend you
and all i get back is that face on your
face
mandy is a blood-soaked acid trip of a
movie that blends a whole host of genres
but in its heavy metal heart mandy is a
horror film
the film boasts nicholas cage as red
miller who wants revenge for his
murdered wife
mandy since we're talking about nick
cage that means doing battle with demons
and getting into chainsaw fights with
psycho hippies
from the moment his wife is immolated
red begins to lose his mind
it doesn't help any when he samples some
of the world's trippiest lsd
which plunges him deep into the cosmic
darkness
his eyes become fireballs of rage and in
the film's final minutes
he hunts down the members of the hippie
cult that killed his wife
and puts his freshly forged axe to good
use
when he finally confronts the insecure
cult leader jeremiah sand
he crushes the man's skull with his
hands before setting sands church on
fire
as the building burns down for a moment
everything is peaceful
the blood is gone from his face and he
sees the spirit of mandy riding shotgun
he flashes back to the moment they first
met at a club wearing identical t-shirts
but then reality comes crashing back
hard
red is still soaked with gore and
grinning like a madman
and as he drives off to nowhere we see
two eerie planets hanging over the
horizon
is this another world is it all in his
head it's a truly freaky
moment and one that's bound to stir up
debate among horror fans for years to
come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one